I believe Mark Twain once said there's
no such thing as a new idea and it
appears that at Disney this may actually
be a marketing strategy after the huge
success of the Jungle Book remate and
the teaser for the live-action Beauty
and the Beast reaching ninety one point
eight million views in its first day who
needs new ideas I'm Simon and this is
your entertainment news updates
according to Deadline Disney is at least
considering a live-action version of The
Little Mermaid it's celebrated and
beloved 1989 animated movie the site
reported that Disney Chiefs recently
heard a new take and occur Ania
valuating whether to proceed with the
idea
Disney has reportedly had initial
discussions with major producers for the
film however these were not named in the
report Jurassic Park and Warcraft studio
Universal is also making a Little
Mermaid movie with Chloe grace Moretz
lined up to play Ariel The Little
Mermaid is one of Disney's most famous
animated films they kicked off what is
considered to be the Disney Renaissance
its oscar-winning soundtrack featured a
number of now famous songs including
under the sea
according to Deadline Disney has been
encouraged to pursue more live-action
remakes after the huge success of the
newly released the Jungle Book which
made more than 860 million dollars
worldwide
additionally the first teaser trailer
for Disney's Beauty and the Beast
reached over 91 million views in its
first day which set a new industry
record are you a huge Disney buff and
love these live-action remakes or do you
expect more for your money when you
visit the cinema let me know in the
comments or come find me on Twitter I'm
at the jaqen or thanks for watching and
for all your entertainment news keep it
gamespot